we have a Christmas party I throw it a
nice event I've had karaoke there every
year and for me I the the fun of the
party is actually sitting and talking to
people that you get to work with all
year but you never get to sit and talk
to and I find when the karaoke goes on
you can't even concentrate no you got to
get out of there and most people are
very annoying when they karaoke but I
just assumed the whole staff loved it
I'm hearing this morning from will and
Jason and Gary that they hate it as much
as I do and they're saying that it's
like an 80/20 split 20% of the people
love karaoke
Oh an 80 percent absolutely hate it and
I'm like well gee I mean I'd love to
stop the karaoke Gary I didn't realize
that many people hated it like I did I
just thought I didn't want to be the old
stick-in-the-mud this isn't for me and I
think I speak for a decent portion when
I hear karaoke Brian I feel like it's
time to go yeah I always leave when it
starts because I don't wanna you know I
don't know I just don't enjoy it the
really interesting part was you told my
man he could be in charge yeah my man
said to me he wanted to be in charge of
karaoke he's like okay good like be in
charge of karaoke what do i sal used to
be in charge of it but now matt wasn't
charging right lameta
karaoke expert they do karaoke every
week him and his girlfriend lounge the
guys that girlfriend's really changed
him she's change him so much that the
way he acted at the party three years
before when he didn't have her he would
have completely mocked them a method was
at the party right the reason I laugh so
much is because before Matt had a
girlfriend like this yeah if I told him
that I watched the show I didn't
particularly like but I watched it
because my wife wanted to watch it
he called me [ __ ] whipped and lame
right now he's renting tuxedos and
putting on crucible performances but I
thought you guys all loved Carrie oh no
that's why I had it there karaoke time
is time to leave I feel like a machine
go on I'm like all right party's winding
oh whoa but can we explain the Ohama
Matt took over karaoke because it's odd
you know so in South dated he was like
an emcee you need to bring microphone
the hey are you doing Robin you want to
sing a song come over here obnoxious but
whatever it was south right ma'amed
and his girlfriend took over the entire
room and it was like a choreographed
production I miss her CIL's like it
looked like they had rehearsed
everything I wasn't paying attention but
at one point I show like like they were
running around the room and at one point
I saw his girlfriend slide across the
room on her knees in Flashdance it
reminded me of the final scene in dirty
dancing yeah like it was the entire room
was taken up and they ran towards each
other not necessary all right but
they're being entertaining I guess for
sure right out the door rah the singing
is terrible - JD gives up there and he
mumbles away attitude you know copses
did something well for him it's a big
thing but the rest of the second you're
like yeah I just sang I'm awesome like
what you did your girlfriend sister -
your wife excuse me high five you're
like oh this party I think people are
celebrating the JD's come out of his
shell like a special needs person gets
up he could walk Wow what did you sing
googled cuz I I don't I know I'm not a
good singer so I use it in a goofy why
would you sing in front of a hundred
people if you know you're not a good
thing what do you want from me I'll do
something who stepped up I'll do
something ya know I'm not good at
talking to you also so you choose to
communicate through song what song did
you I did shake it off by Taylor Swift
no kidding that's not an easy song could
perform oh good for you somebody told me
you smoked weed around the corner from
the restaurant I got that report KD do
you do it live exactly mumble
yeah come on in I can get you the world
who got high with JD anybody I know you
weren't no I I I got high before you got
hot you weren't and you weren't invited
yeah I thought Scott though I'm Tanya
I'm not joking the second I started
singing I was now Ronnie was one of the
people I saw in Japan
oh you really run I gave JD a little
weed care package for his birthday baby
I'm just gonna shake shake shake shake
shake it off shake it off Heartbreakers
gonna break break break break
fake fake fake fake baby I'm just gonna
shake shake shake shake shake shake it
off shake it off what's not so bad ever
miss it be laid it on my feet you wanna
keep singing her kind of just reads the
words though it's like a poet cuz I
don't want to get up there make an ass
of myself huh sorry I had to say at
least JD's trying we have tape of Benji
Benji iris near this I am fade a bit
Benji like just gets up and starts
yelling into the microphone I actually
do ended with Benji during this and he
screamed right in my face it was very
dark
is that his whole thing is to yell i
with this song I guess I don't know
here's Benji doing his thing so like I
don't know man I'm at a holiday party I
just want to [ __ ] talk to people he's
met to defend I'm Albert
listen to Benji doing
[Music]
lyrics he just wants to get up and
scream are you gonna defend karaoke I
wasn't even gonna say anything but these
guys are the biggest kiss-asses you
should know they all came to me this
morning and said they don't like care
after they heard you say their mind
changes like that well babe we're gonna
say that to make them happy entire
vacation break first of all these guys
are going out there like they're doing
mushrooms they're partying till like
damn a party with you and they're like
oh how it absolutely the karaoke was
going on too late I wanted to enjoy
really think you're lying quietly of
course they're full of [ __ ] if anything
I would save a little bit money on the
food and have the karaoke go a little
bit long Benji you love the food no at
the party usually you don't why
everywhere else well it's I guess I did
nervousness or whatever I totally sound
like a guy who's nervous on that karaoke
but okay that was the end of the song
that was the end of the song but still
it's beautiful captured the [ __ ] end
of the song but the actual song you're
terrible
I'll ask ask rasoi was there beautiful
son what his respond though he knows how
beautiful I sing that song amazing
amazing by Aerosmith yeah I mean let me
sing it good use finger good I'd be
happy to but I'll listen to you sing but
are you really good parts to Solomon I'm
amazing
alright go ahead I need the words again
like thematic question do I do what that
word dude I don't know what this is all
right Rick get outta get some more
we'll get to you later
I don't want to see the karaoke go away
so I can take back the hosting duties
but for me again I thought everybody
loved karaoke but me I leave when it
starts because I can't take it I don't
want to hear Benji screeching I don't
want to hear South singing I don't want
to do it it's in all seriousness if you
don't like karaoke you have three hours
of party before the karaoke what I said
well that's what I said how long do you
need to talk Gary
saying they go home to once that thing
starts I don't want people to go home I
wanted to continue drinking and eating
and having a good time how long did you
and Mary rehearse the number that you
guys did for the party that's zero we
craft one heart running across the room
sliding on the and you meeting her that
was just impromptu yeah Jenny told us
you do the same dance move at every
craft maybe I only have one dance move I
don't even know what you're talking
about what song no we know it's not true
we know that you were dancing around
oh I danced and sang during karaoke but
Tommy's your what your girlfriend slid
across the dance floor on her knees the
song was mr. Roboto I do I tell you what
exactly what a remind me of I thought
you guys did a good job but it was like
the cheerleading sketch on SNL I was
dancing dear see this is how I approach
being a host not this is interesting but
like I wanted to make everyone feel
because sometimes we'd get them do
karaoke no one's paying attention
so it's Hulse I'm like I'm gonna dance
when they're singing their song like I'm
gonna move around get people interested
in their motive so maybe you'll feel
good about singing right I'd rather no
music no lyrical music at all or if we
do have music the karaoke actually was
kind of fun something that you know what
I'm gonna do Benji I'm in all fairness
I'm gonna take a private vote but peace
that's a good idea and let and whoever
decides they want karaoke can privately
let me know I would take a vote right
now
people might be intimidating I predict
the vote will be 70% against I bet you
tired it might be it's so horrible
wait it'll be 80% ass-kissers and 20%
people there's gonna be a private vote
no one no one had no one is going to be
affected other than when they go to the
party all right private vote how come an
ass-kisser why can't I just have an
opinion I just think some people you
wait to hear what Howard has I did not
wait worked with them long enough you
know what he's gonna say you think Gary
is kissing my ass by saying he doesn't
like the karaoke I think could I just
not like it you probably honestly
convinced yourself you don't like it I
don't like it with it I don't know I
Gary don't you know you're not allowed
to disagree with my met without there
being of everyone has two personalities
here the one where they're in front of
you and the one where they're in what
you're saying basically is Gary has said
he likes the karaoke to you everyone so
Gary's lying right now he likes to
karaoke you said you liked it Gary say
he didn't like I believe he would I
don't think Gary's ever been afraid to
give me his opinion to come in here and
say it sucked in the nice sake walked up
to Gary Matt I did walk up to Gary I saw
Gary a few days after the Christmas
party he walked up to me and literally
the first words out of his mouth where
did you see that disaster of a karaoke
at Howard's what can I say something
take a vote back there organize a vote
if the vote goes no karaoke I'll be
thrilled because I'll stay longer at the
party too I'm gonna go do that right now
I had the vote so we the question was do
you want karaoke back at the party next
year if there is a party of the yeses I
just want to say three people have
caveats the answer is yes but only from
a met is not hosting and you get a
better karaoke sound system okay but the
answer was nine people suggest they very
much want karaoke back next year
eighteen said No
you can get the monthly mind I put your
both poster okay and Gary's what you say
the best kissers how are they kissing my
ass but I don't know who they are there
are no secrets in this place you know
that and I won't host karaoke next year
even if you begged me good next year
when it's a house robbery
I didn't have a problem with you host he
was Harry okey you were fine thank you
I'm just saying the whole karaoke thing
is annoying it's just annoying and I
disagree and I look at you see what
happens Howard when you throw a party
for nuts
you